[Applause]
exciting news from the world of science
this week i don't know if you saw this
but there was an engineer at google who
says that uh ai has gone sentient
meaning uh chat bots you know in a chat
bot of course being anything that we
talk to that isn't really real like siri
or you know as soon as you call up a
company and ask a question and you think
you're having a conversation you're like
oh i'm talking to a robot here
who apparently is more knowledgeable
than the person they could hire or
certainly certainly cheaper right there
you go uh
anyway this engineer said well now they
have gone sentient which is scary
because that's i've seen too many movies
where the robots get sentient and then
guess who dies
okay now google said
he's not right but maybe he is anyway i
think he might be onto something
and we sure smelled a comedy bit
so these are some ways you know if your
ai has gone sentient would you like to
hear them i i know you're right
for example
um
your computer keeps sexting neil
degrasse tyson it's just
a sure fire
you ask alexa to play christopher cross
and she says what is this 1973.
[Laughter]
uh when you eat taco bell in the car it
automatically rolls down the window
oh yeah you know how when your tv asks
are you still watching it then says
because this show sucks
[Applause]
your smart soap dispenser moans before
it squirts
[Applause]
your washing machine accuses ed sheeran
of stealing the little song it plays
when the load is finished
[Laughter]
play it again
thank you
that is an ed sheeran song wait a second
you ask siri if something is wrong and
she says i don't know is there
[Applause]
uh you're teleprompted it tells you to
go itself hey wait a second
[Applause]
you